I'm confused about the mixed messages about seed oils on the internet.
They're either from the devil, or they're wonderful. Depending on what site you read.
I notice my dietary oil recommendations from cutters, cutters, clinic were devoid of any seed or not oils, other than walnut oil.
But when I've asked about sunflower oil, and Ted told me that it was okay to take it,
some people do say that the problem with those seed oils is how they're processed, not with the seed oils themselves.
Others say they're generally unhealthy, or our gut's work designed to handle them.
There are a lot of mixed messages about seed oils.
And so let's kind of talk about that. Just try to be brief.
So the, the camp that says seed oils are good for you is the camp that says that, you know, a mother oil or a parent oil is really what we were meant to eat.
We were meant to eat parent oils, not EPA DHA from cold water fish.
So parent oils will break down to that and will break down to other oils that other fats that you needed your body.
And there's a lot of sense that I think about how we were created. I think there's a lot of sense to that that camp.
And I don't, you know, I don't think we were created and put in a garden that was close to cold water fish.
And so, you know, we were created initially to eat plants. Now I'm not vegan by any search of imagination.
I do think we should be eating meat for sure. And I think cold water fish is fantastic. And taking omega three fatty acids. It's just fine.
But I don't think that everybody every human being on the planet needs to go and start eating cold water fish and start taking omega three fatty acids.
It's good to say there's people groups that have lived and they're even in blue zones that live well over a hundred years old and they've never touched omega three fatty acid and it's pure fish oil form in their life.
And so there's different cultures that do better because of genetic variations in that culture on different food groups.
So I come from more Irish German background and I think that that there's nothing wrong with me from that background and culture of not eating a lot of cold water fish.
But eating some cold water fish. I don't personally don't take omega three fatty acid capsules. Again, I'm not in a fan of you guys taking a hundred different supplements either.
So, so I do I eat cold water fish. Yes, do I try to eat all line caught type fish fresh, not processed, not.
From the ocean fish, absolutely. Yes, I think it's good for you. There's a lot of benefits to it. But I also don't want to say that all seed oils are bad either. I'm not in that camp either.
I take a middle of the road pathway partly depends on your heritage. If you're more Norwegians Swedish heritage, you will probably do really well on cold water fish and they might actually do better for you.
If you're getting omega three fatty acids, if you're more Mediterranean and Asian and culturally and more African culturally or probably do better on seed oils.
So you got to look at those things too. How their process is definitely an issue, though, too.
If they're cold water cold pressed process cereals are going to be much better for much better for you, plus if they're organic. So, you know, the world, one of the one of the things that we might be having issues with seed oils is that they're sprayed.
So they might be GMO, they're highly processed and that's really what's wrong with it. My mind what's really wrong with seed oils.